salut aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé personne à
mentaliser donc je vais vous mentaliser
vous on va faire une expérience
interactive un petit bluff comme ça
entre nous mais pour ça il faut que vous
soyez concentré absolument sur la vidéo
cette expérience va être basée sur
quelque chose que vous connaissez bien
sur youtube il s'agit des pouces en
l'air et des poussins pas les fameux
pouce en bas j'ai une anecdote par
rapport au pouce en bas depuis le début
que je fais les vidéos donc depuis
mi-janvier à peu près tous les jours au
moment où je mets la vidéo moins d'une
minute après j'ai deux pouces en bas ce
sont les mêmes personnes qui se
précipitent pour mettre un pouce en bas
c'est devenu une mission pour eux le
plus drôle c'est que quand même je
connais un des deux personnellement et
bien je te remercie parce que tu m'as
donné l'idée de faire cette vidéo vous
voyez donc maintenant apparaître un
pouce en l'air et un coup samba mettez
votre doigt sur un des deux pouces celui
qui en l'air ou celui qui est en bas
c'est vous qui choisissez vous mettez
votre doigt sur l'un des deux pouces
vous allez maintenant épauler votre
prénom et à chaque lettre que vous allez
vous allez bouger votre doigt d'une
seule case j'explique histoire que ce
soit bien clair si j'ai décidé de mettre
mon doigt sur le pouce en bas pour
commencer et que j'appelle mon prénom
donc fabien je vais bouger en fabioalex8
tj soit sur un des deux pouces celui que
vous avez choisi au départ maintenant
alesi et pelé votre nom et à chaque
lettre que vous appelez vous changez
votre doigt de pouce je crois que c'est
pas exactement ça il fallait faire vous
avez maintenant terminer votre doigt et
sur un des deux pouces si votre doigt
sur le pouce vert vous allez épeler le
mot verve et ert en changeant votre
doigt deux places à chaque fois que vous
appelez une lettre et si votre doigt et
sur le pouce rouge vous faites la même
chose mais en épaulant le mot rouge six
mois par exemple j'étais sur le rouge
jeffrey r o u etc etc
si vous êtes sur le verre vous épeler le
mot vert si vous êtes sûr rouge vous
épauler le mot rouge c'est parti est ce
coup ci c'est bon vous êtes arrivé sur
un pouce sur un pouce et un seul pouce
et c'est sur ce pour cela que vous
cliquerez à la fin de la vidéo pouce en
l'air c'était une petite vidéo du mardi
un peu différente voilà on a fait un jeu
entre nous espérons que ce jeu là vous
et plus demain c'est le jour des astuces
je vais vous donner des astuces sur les
techniques des manipulateurs demain
également donc mercredi soir à 20h50 sur
la chaîne numéro 23 donc en prime time
une émission qui s'appelle dossier
surnaturel sur les mentalistes les
hypnotiseur etc et j'y serai en tant que
mentalist si jamais vous regardez faites
le moi savoir sur twitter en mettant
notre jeu tabanou le hashtag team menthe
à l'eau c'est le hashtag qu'on a
déterminés l'autre jour lors du live sur
périscope c'était samedi
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne et rendez vous de demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao